fight fans it is finally here UFC 251
you can get your boys together maybe
you're not maybe you're gonna quarantine
and be by yourself but you want to watch
the fights you want to make money
there's no better place to do it than
with draftkings that on all the big
fights from the prelims to the main card
bet right with draft kings all you do is
download the app start betting there's a
bunch of dogs get on it fellas get on it
ladies and gentlemen get on it download
the top rated draftkings sports book app
now use the code fighter when you sign
up for a limited time all new users can
get a signup bonus of $1,000 that's
right
draftkings sports book has a signup
bonus up to $1,000 just enter the code
fighter when you sign up only at
draftkings sports book UFC 251 make bank
do it with draftkings yeah the first
thing I'd like to say is that I heard
through the grapevine that a 1 cat got a
little older ride a cat yeah well I'd
like to I'd like to do a little happy
birthday
[Music]
[Music]
you're 23 25 25 I don't remember that
what's it like young it's great I still
don't really have any bodily aches yeah
yeah no because you don't have Cobra
hopefully I don't if I do I have very
mild symptoms have you been feeling sick
I've had like no I don't have like lost
ov sounds like scent or taste or
anything like that you probably any
symptomatic of you really if you are
exposed everybody that I've been in
contact widget after Texas so far as
tested completely negative mmm and had
no symptoms whatsoever which is a big
relief for me and I will say that I I've
been a little humbled and I apologize
because I was not careful enough when I
came back it's one thing to take a risk
on my own which I've always taken
responsibility for to say I'm gonna go
I'm gonna do prominent you stand up and
if I catch that I catch it but I wasn't
I wasn't thinking on many levels which
was dumb I had to go see my parents on
Friday it never dawned on me to be even
more careful
iiiiii exposed some friends without
thinking about it so all of that stuff
was my Mia culpa I was wrong and I
apologize I think I was little I was
inconsiderate and and I've I've been
humbled because this this is lingering
for me this is not this is not it's not
like I'm over it this is a I'm fine but
I can see people not being fine
obviously as we know if you're old or
you have existing morbidities it's very
dangerous so I've been I've been a
little humbled I will continue to stand
up as long as those states or allow me
to I do want to reiterate that Brandon
and I when we went to Texas we've been
to Houston we've been Arizona we had to
go ahead to go do stand-up by the Board
of Health by the club
by the state okay that's how we earn a
living and and because Ben and I looked
at the stats well part of it would
that's how we looked at the stats and we
looked at the risk we chose to make that
decision I take full responsibility for
it could I have been more careful coming
back yes and I wasn't and I apologize
so that's right I'd say yeah I mean if
you would have told me that I'd have to
be away from my family for two weeks
because of this I would have done any of
the shows I don't know if I'm gonna do
more shows in July either I don't know
if it's worth it so well yeah yeah I'm
gonna have to push Addison but but
Brennan you're um you're now you now
have the antibodies yeah I'm aware I'm
it's more of I would be fine it's more I
don't know yeah I don't know well that's
that's how I feel it's like you know I'm
gonna sit over here cuz I don't I think
my face looks better
yeah III I think I feel like I I know
what you're saying like I just feel like
there's a was too [ __ ] bright that is
to worry right that's that's always the
worry how the [ __ ] are we gonna how do
you keep other people you know safe but
but I do have to say that I think that
anybody who has antibodies is probably
maybe a smart way to do it is you can go
back in the workforce yeah agree agree
mm-hmm I mean I do it cuz I like doing
it I don't have to do it and it's just
like you know is it you know I don't
know I'm weighing the pros and the cons
and figuring everything out yeah it's a
little humbling when you get sick
yeah I've been fortunate enough where it
hasn't been too bad at all you know
thank God but yeah if I could redo it I
wouldn't I wouldn't a wet you know it's
just not worth it to risk my family and
stuff like that I really didn't think
about how I was really thinking about it
was like you and me and doing the shows
and everyone think about it here and
then I get home that's like ah [ __ ] you
I got two little kids my girl my girl
gets it the family super fun
because she takes care everyone you know
so it's like and then you know of course
my my involves can't come over cuz my my
my father-in-law who's a cop you know
here's a lung issue so it's like alright
well he can't come over and see his
grandkids now this was like just stupid
man yeah I yeah I literally didn't think
of any of this because I'm an idiot like
I have to I'll be I'll be honest I was
going to see my parents on Friday and I
and I they're 80 and I didn't even think
of that
so I I was very tone-deaf to it so yeah
I said I'm sorry you good as soon as I
can
tour these three cities or he can wait
till August and tour when it's safe
because it's not saying though that the
promise it's not safe and that the
province is never going to be safe and
I'm not waiting I have to say this - I'm
not waiting until the vaccine comes out
I can't no and I don't think any of us
can I think that this is the dilemma
that we're in as an economy and there's
a world
III I think if you're if you're a
journalist if you're a politician if you
are somebody who has a job no matter
what if you have reserves you can you
can talk about a shutdown last in two
years I think the most most people can't
know that time yeah so yeah I don't
think I don't think
nothing says August or September is
safer than [ __ ] July so so I wonder I
wonder if somebody I'm not hearing
alternatives well yeah herd immunity
hopefully you know enough people get it
there's a herd immunity yes they think
happened in New York because they had
such a spike there and now it's down so
they're thinking that's what happened
there so the good news is the death
rates down ninety two point something
percent correct we're not gonna make
this a Koba thing I just wanted to
apologize eat a little crow sorry to be
a [ __ ] idiot but that's not the first
time for me anyway what else went on
this weekend cuz I've been in my [ __ ]
house done nothing dude it's brutal
brutal brutal I get guys in hazmat suits
right now in the house like they have
this weird like smoke
finger going over the whole house with
oh you oh really okay yeah that's what's
that let's get rid of 99.9 genic Ovid
there we go we've got the big UFC this
weekend I hopefully will be able to do a
fight companion with Rogan that'd be
good
that'd be good I still got a test
negative though I gotta go get tested
yeah I talked to my doctor about that he
said the issue is you know when when you
take the testing since so doctor you
have it could still show that you you
know you don't have symptoms you're not
contagious could still show up three to
six months after it's a weird Wiley
[ __ ] virus yeah I know he's saying
he's like those tests aren't the end-all
be-all so you gotta be kidding
I've I've talked to a number of doctors
who are like a lot of them just shake
your head and they're like maybe I don't
know depends it's like yeah okay but the
thing the CDC says is you know if it's
three days without a fever three days
without any symptoms between eight to
fourteen days after you first got it
then you can go all right Brennan UFC
251 stack card I gotta be honest with
you not a gambling man but so intriguing
because there are so many different
factors and you can't bet on this unless
you understand the game but III there's
one thing I love doing and that's
watching the UFC I wonder if I could
have a watched UFC and make money at the
same time my knowledge I'd fight I'm
glad you brought this up I'm using draft
Kings draft kings there's no better time
to start then this Saturday UFC 250 ones
you use draft kings man download the app
and all you got to do is bet on your
face there's a bunch of underdogs you
parlay it make your ton of Bank man make
Bank download the top raid draftkings
sports book app now use the code fighter
when you sign up for limit I'm all new
users can get a signup bonus up to
$1,000 that's right
draftkings sports book has a signup
bonus up to $1,000 just enter the code
fighter when you sign up only a drafting
sports book you and I have been known
you
no and some of our friends been known to
wager on quite a lot of dogs here's that
here's a dogs for you miles did all
three to 100 dog Josie Allen wonder dog
Wow all weight underdog so you got three
dogs take page reinvents the biggest
undercard on the card you must be 21 or
older to enter New Jersey Colorado PA
only bonus comprised of first deposit
bonus and first bet match each up to
$500 deposit deposit bonus requires 25
times play through restrictions apply
see draft kings.com slash sports book
for details gambling problem call
winning our gambler there you go
draftkings I'll tell you what
besides my toothbrush I might use more
than anything else that's my manscaped
3.0 I've noticed your nose hairs aren't
saying hello anymore dude i keeping trim
my eyebrows my body hair my bud hair my
might my sack is just as smooth as it
gets to man thinking yeah get that feels
kind of woody dotted dreams it's got a
light it's got an adjuster and you won't
snag your nuts that's a big deal do you
have a snag your nuts because I have its
you snag your nuts because you're
cutting your nut here with your lights
off now you can do it in the dark what
you can do in the dark it's got this
tiny little light on it sauce you can
see all these stray hairs no reason to
be hairy like a Russian anymore dude
there's no reason to be that hairy any
more like Andrei Arlovski dude you want
here on your shoulders
you don't hear you want neck here nose
here body here you don't your hairy bush
thank God for manscape well manscape
this awesome for your nether regions the
regions you can't afford to Nick they
have that patented technology that lets
you not get nicked that's a big deal
Ryan give them an offer will you like
give them the offer I I don't have the
offer in front of me I just go with what
I know and what I have I'll buy doing
this kind of stuff
well it's manscape comp remote is
fighter Brian the promo code is finder
power quarter spider-man scam calm there
is no better
there is no better machine for keeping
you skate as a man what a man scaped
what else you gonna use what the hell
else you gonna use sighs manscape it's
funny when you see it and you wonder why
it wasn't invented before we're like
it's it why wasn't I first to me like
this is a great idea yeah I get the
perfect package right now get two amps
off and free shipping with the coach
fighter at manscape calm do yourself a
favor
Oh use the right tools for the job
that's twice off free shipping with a
code fighter at manscape comm tribe sent
off free shipping manscape communes code
fighter trim your chest schools with the
beste khals that's right it's get the
perfect package for your package yeah
well did you see the news nads with all
fightin Maz adults fighting loose mom
and I can't [ __ ] wait when is he
fighting
what's mom well sounds like you can't
wait cuz you have no idea when they're
fighting so what are they fighting are
they fighting this Saturday something
can definitely wait you had no idea what
they're fighting so that makes me very
happy
you put all your money on who I want to
put money on anybody
just because yeah Mazda no it's just
gonna be a wrestler against [ __ ]
Stryker right yeah you did nothing on
your birthday just to kind of see the
outside without interacting with someone
I force my sister to drive me everywhere
that day Oh your sister was your little
uber driver
yeah it's great I haven't had to drive
since she's moved in so I'm just kind of
forcing her to do all the [ __ ] that I
don't want to do and she's well she's
not in school right now cuz it's not
school anywhere mmm she graduated
this year actually oh hey this is
awesome but I wanted to talk a little
bit more about loose mom monster doll
appreciate that I don't use ask me it's
a wrestler versus striking well well in
a lot of ways it is in a lot of ways
you've got a much better wrestler
fighting a much better strike and that's
that's a fair comparison now you have
which mother doesn't seem to get tired
if he doesn't cats I haven't seen I
haven't seen cardio be an issue with
Mozgov doll either but I do think whose
mom is physically he just seems so
[ __ ] huge compared to any hundred and
seventy powder
yeah he's bigger for sure so the
question is I don't know man it's gonna
be really interesting the whole cards
stacked I can't wait who else is on a
card you mention I don't think they
updated the main event yet for whatever
reason UFC calm oh they did today I
think see they didn't this morning when
we're doing below the belt they did it
finally mean card that's a good fight so
that hold the whole thing about max
Holloway having weight issues was fake
no it's fake yeah that's from a troll
account [ __ ]
Peter Yan Jose Aldo whoa Rose gets a
fight with Jessica again holy [ __ ] I
can't wait haven't seen haven't heard
from Paige in a while
yep you're the whole cards stacked
mm-hmm great I [ __ ] thought there's
me or went to a different fight me Lulu
those two men both can yeah I thought he
went to a different I wait for some
reason no yeah it's tough hopefully I'll
do the campaigning for that because they
usually just do fight nights not that's
a stat pay-per-view
next [ __ ] gonna be really good and then
you really get Mazel
tomorrow if they both passed their Koba
test once they arrived one fine island -
oh is that right you have to take it
here and then they have to fly there and
take it again I feel like I'm in jail I
feel like I'm not even talking to
anybody right now
Chinn have you been quarantine
yeah yeah chin Chin's had the same
symptoms as Stevie he said like this the
night sweats you had last night and this
morning I didn't sleep at all last night
maybe like 20 minutes but then I so how
do you how do you feel are you having a
paddock sickness right now I feel better
but then I just developed a cough like
this early morning but now I'm not
coughing right now either I want to ask
you guys about the whole the fevers
stuff so as a gesture head or is it your
body I didn't really suffer from fever
I don't yeah I didn't get a fever at all
either I have the temp thing Jen because
the iTap for my kid - its let's go to
school so we take a stamp every day so
now the school he goes to if they take
their tenth there if their attempts hide
they pull up they get him out they
didn't let him into school so before he
enters the school they run his tab so
before he goes so we don't waste
anybody's time we always run his even
before I go bit or anything run his tab
okay yeah you if you have fever be in
your head that's where you can take you
to him I think this thing manifests
itself differently in a lot of different
people
hey how about how about I was Thea went
home to his parents you know his mom's
like ninety nine years old and so I
takes the art I go cuz he got coded
tested and I take them yesterday I go
hey dude how you feeling
he just responds back terrible like all
caps
I got shitty O's I go what's going what
do you feel he goes he goes my ass is
really swollen and then dot dot and my
nose is really swollen dot dot dot and
have a moment
[Laughter]
Oh dick he is no but it's not good man I
hit this fat-ass and he's big this big
nose no not sick like you I mean I wake
up a lot of times I'm just stiff and
[ __ ] feel like [ __ ] generally so you
don't have energy here you know you
didn't sleep well
so now just add some that I can I think
you're fine why are you not going to get
tested I did it don't know you came back
negative
oh don't get me started on it haven't
getting mirrors my results yet and they
also haven't scheduled me for my second
test I'm supposed to get both of them
together but they couldn't find someone
they never called me back never text me
back I just have I was like calling and
constantly finally I get someone they'll
call you back will call you back they
never call back
hey B how has your appetite been not
very good
mine's me well I can't taste or smell a
[ __ ] thing that's what's weird I
can't pay for smell anything but I am
just Cookie Monster over here yeah oh
the roof if I had cookies already
cookies right now I may need all the
cookies in fact Jason [ __ ] in fact I
might make a bunch of cookie dough what
else you gonna do you know I can't taste
it that's just gonna feel like [ __ ]
cook go in my mouth I know that's a
problem I wonder when the taste is gonna
come back
my doctor said take zinc tablets which
I've been doing meat ever since you talk
that they don't help at all Podcast oh
it's the worst this is the Kovan this is
the corporate podcast and you if you
don't dive coffee go die affordable
let's go to some Colonel venture talk to
me how I'm gonna talk to you about it
dude while you're at home doing those
workouts in your undies do you know how
many calories you're burning do you know
if you got the proper rest last night no
I don't you don't dude and no one really
does we're just been bro signs in our
entire lives dude I don't know what kind
of strain I'm putting my body on I don't
know if I should train today I don't
have anybody
honoring that nobody's monitoring my
heartbeat nobody's monitoring when I
have a spike when I don't why I do now
what if I told you just wear a little
black band around your wrist and it will
monitor all that talk about whoop dude
I'm talking about woo woo calm wh Oh
okey yes dude whoop and it connects to
your cell phone device it monitors your
heart rate a hundred times per second
your strain activity your recovery you'd
even Mars your sleep cycle you sleep
with this thing done you think in eight
hours sleeping all the rest in the world
I ant news for you you're probably not
man take the bro science out of it whoop
is the best athletic sports device you
can wear these days and there was that
golfer who found because it was
measuring turbans and you may be sick
crazy right and also can wear it in the
pool you can wear in the shower you
never have to take it off to waterproof
the battery lasts forever five days five
days now connect to your phone take the
guesswork out man this is the best
workout device I've ever used I love
these guys whoo calm promo code fighter
you save 15% off the entire damn signup
sheet
alright you sign up you'll access 15%
off woot.com promo code fight have you
guys heard about Kanye West coming out
and saying that he wants to run for
president in 2020 yes
it's insane yeah so he made an
announcement saying that he wanted to
run for president
um Elan musk has come out in full
support of him on Twitter so did his
wife Kim Kardashian and as a joke
Tiffany Haddish came out and said that
she will also be running for president
in 2020 and Dave Chappelle is gonna be
running with her I mean what a good show
you know what's scary is I mean if Trump
can win [ __ ] Kanye can win apparently
he hasn't done anything leading up to
this announcement to get him actually
like on the polls so I don't think I can
win it is no idea what it entails it's
just I think Kanye also has a history of
mental illness and I don't think he's
gonna be Americans are like
again good artists I mean we thought
that about Trump done then here we are
huh sure I couldn't know I'm an obvious
the one with or saying there's no ways
yeah you're on record saying there's not
a chance not a chance and then we had
Chael Sonnen on said he's gonna win that
was like no and here's why I went
through the whole read the litany of
reasons I was wrong I mean that's it
it's funny how when you live in
Hollywood you think that sometimes you
start to think maybe this is [ __ ]
reality and Hollywood's biggest problem
was telling you this is that they are
putting out movies and TV shows that
nobody's watching and now you add coded
to it and they don't know how to get
bonded insured and what's happening is
YouTube and original content people who
are doing their own thing are sort of
killing the old Hollywood model so that
Hollywood then nominates poor people who
won Oscars and nobody knows who they are
and nobody even goes to see those movies
nobody went saw a moonlight well no one
watch the Oscars either
there's the Oscars no so you have these
people are talking and then you know
it's like even CNN CNN is what people
watch a lot of times when they're in the
airport going from place to place but
CNN's ratings are super low tank wonder
whose ratings are doing good though well
you're all foxes is it positive it's all
pro-trump
well Tucker Carlson and certain Fox
things are yeah some of its weight
something that's ridiculously blindly
Pro Trump but I think the country is
still a little bit more conservative
than people realize I think the CNN
rightly or wrongly says you see CNS PC
or whatever whatever the [ __ ] it's
called me and the rightly or wrongly did
the perception is that they are super
act they're not journalists they're
activists they're blindly left-wing and
so when people see that or they hear
that it's a hard thing to lose it's a
hard thing to think I mean even ESPN
ratings are down like what's doing well
right now you know
yeah just being dedicated like two weeks
to I think black lives matter right mmm
yeah apparently their ratings are not
good not doing very well I don't know
anything that's doing I mean the UFC's
doing well yeah yeah some things I mean
that plates like Tiger king crushed it
you know what I watched I watched I
rewatched the Super Bowl yesterday Jesus
Christ did it made me feel good there
were crowds there's nothing worse than
old sports I'll tell you what was weird
NASCAR with no crowd it's just this
giant you know that that Indy 500
whatever's the largest crowd the largest
stadium in America and I'm into it no
one's there I've been to it and then I
watched premier league soccer and I
heard a crowd I'm like Oh sick
there's crowds but they just they're
pumping sound in so it seemed like a
crowd here say this is an impressive
time I think Korean baseball has stuffed
animals in the crowd they do Jesus
Christ they do stuffed animals
we're being replaced human beings are
robots and I mean I well I'll be
interesting with the NBA looks like and
I'm not just being a Homer here but I do
think that you have seen without a crowd
is the best for football that a crowds
gonna suck baseball data crowds gonna
suck
basketballs probably gonna suck you have
seen you don't really mind David know
because there's the cage there and it's
kind of like it's not it still has a
good vibe to it
yeah it doesn't pray I said he'd much
rather fight without a crowd just about
right knocks another crowd though that's
what's interesting
yeah have you tried watching boxing it's
so - no I haven't I mean not not without
a crowd but yeah I rewatched there's a
documentary on the Buster Douglas Mike
Tyson fight that's what that's why I've
been watching 3030
yeah pretty interesting now it's called
42 in one or something well I thought
this is no [ __ ] joke man no [ __ ]
joke but yeah I'm watching that uh
you'll hear me in the dark or something
like that that I can
John the the Golden State rapist guy
that they caught yeah yeah well the
first episode was you know getting into
it in the second episode it's gold now
it's just it's it's just because he
raped over 50 women and it's all the
survivors talking about how he did it
but he did it same every time so it's
like you have to hear the first seven so
what would he do have fetish what was
his fetish raping girls but then he
would kill and he would kill their
boyfriends her husband no he's no 12
right Duggar you raped over 50 killed 12
took 12 women yeah man
I think women but then he what this is
what's interesting they found out he was
a cop so what an evil piece piece of
[ __ ] so he would like scope out the
houses and cuz we're there in Sacramento
you could get a what get did access to
the backyards cuz there's like this huge
loop he would use to go down and scape
there's bad fog in the 70s so he could
escape in the night and I guess he had a
real small penis - okay yeah makes sense
yeah so he would he was a sadist right
he would make make them stay there and
put you know cups up yeah wait which way
to me is like in the 70s no one I done
door anything it's like this serial
rapist was going on don't have alarms or
guns or Nothing man so he was able to
get it done it's terrible just taught
him didn't they see its faced no you are
a white ski mask yeah
another thing you knew is he had a
little dick evil man dude you tie would
tie him up walk around the house go into
the kitchen drink their beer come back
it's crazy man yeah well serial killers
and people like that are into power
there incest subjugating their victims
you'd be tough to do it now though with
cell phones and stuff
that like you never really hear about a
serial rapist these days because with
Bob there's cameras everywhere now
there's security there's guns like it's
just well that's that's that's the good
thing about having a lot of cameras yeah
is it you can you know people are
watching so you can't get away with [ __ ]
like that hmm
so for all all we talk about privacy and
stuff
the reason the Mafia doesn't kill people
anymore is because they can be seen
reason we catch a lot of criminals like
that like serial rapists and stuff
because they're cameras everywhere and
you can go oh well that guy's there and
then you just follow the cameras you can
follow traffic cams and all that yeah I
was watching the John Gotti it's John
Gotti Jr and his dad the gaudy story
John Gotti you know in the 70s 80s and
early 90s in New York City it's crazy
how famous he was it's good I was I was
in your own tongue it's not sure I you
see even a place called Cafe Sorrento
and it was right next door the ravenite
Club which was his club I never saw
Gotti but I remember just when I was a
young man eating outside and I saw two
three dudes come out of that rave
nightclub they were in suits they were
guys don't like you and they were
walking and they were on their way
somewhere I never forgot it
I never forgot it I saw them and I had a
deep bone chill cuz I knew him instantly
they weren't just big guys they were
killers and you could see it if they
came out of the ravenite club you were
like and he was always a guy was a
driver there and he had an earpiece and
he was there it's crazy to me that John
Gotti like he was so beloved like little
Little Italy and New York loved the [ __ ]
out of man yeah cuz he was like he would
be hanging out and people like he'd eat
dinner and stuff from yet well you know
Matthew Broderick was with Marlon Brando
and they were eating and at the time
actor Broderick was very famous in
American Marlon Brando played The
Godfather so they were eating in New
York they were right next door
apparently and they get a guy comes up
and says mr. Gotti would like to invite
you to the ravenite club
say hello do you have a drink so Brando
and [ __ ]
you know they're like alright I mean
there's super famous they're like
alright so they get there and and and
they're playing cards oh come on oh so
now it's Brando John Gotti jeez his
henchman and [ __ ] Matthew Broderick
was an after like me he's like this kind
of guy thing he's married to Sarah
Jessica Parker he's a Broadway singer
yeah oh hi these guys have your pieces
tats big and [ __ ] when he's like oh yeah
I know what the guy looks something says
you could kid in the neighborhood huh
yeah yeah anybody give you problem you
let us know and so he goes so proud of
it goes cool how would you find him
though and he goes fine [ __ ] awesome
you don't they were there saying how
like the reason why the Mafia now we've
talked about this because that that RICO
Act you know governor Giuliani started
in we're now you know if you get caught
with mafia [ __ ] man
so these guy they're saying now the the
mafia it I was this was the rabbit hole
I went down I was like is there still an
Italian mafia and there's still the five
families but they just operate
completely different they don't want any
attention they want zero attention now
oh they were pissed how the famous John
Gotti got they didn't got all the
attention on them so they hated biggest
that was rule number one you never do
that you can't be famous in a criminal
you [ __ ] they found the number one
Chinese Triad guy the [ __ ] guy who
ran Chinese mafia
the most powerful like most he was
[ __ ] he had a food cart in Thailand
he was known it was in New York City we
had a [ __ ] food cart he was making
food you know just like completely like
what I did I guess the number one like
mafia guy right now who's still out and
about and he was on FBI's top five list
he's a Russian but he gets exempt
because he's with who
couldn't give him an exemption so he's
in yes well putting the biggest gangster
city grant but this guy was on the FBI's
top top five for years and and now he's
in Asian and now now he's in Russia and
they can't touch him Americans can't
touch her it's scary but it's different
to with John Gotti Jr cuz you know when
his dad went away he wanted his son to
run it means like you know I have four
kids man and he went away for I think
fraud so tax fraud he went away for like
six years and things like when I'm out
I'm done man so they have the video of
him telling his dad he wants out and his
dad even then man is just tough as balls
just like oh you you're gonna give him
and you're getting he's like I don't
want this life man I'm gonna raise my
[ __ ] kids like well Katya Gotti was
Scotty was the real guide I knew God his
lawyer Bruce Cutler I did a show with
Bruce so they call the wheel bulldogs or
some like that yeah III yeah Bruce was
Bruce looked like a gangster Bruce was
thinking [ __ ] very smart great guy at
the time he was dead defending still
Specter and Bruce told me he said I I
have defended very formidable men that
guy lived it that guy was as real in
every sense of the word as it was he was
just [ __ ] you know he was he was I
guess the the guy who played for keeps
willing to go go away forever but then
he did turn yeah well they said his uh
his rule was he didn't want anybody
around him who didn't serve time in
prison because he only trusts guys that
were from the street and then Sammy the
bull who had eventually ended up you
know snitching on him
never served in time in prison but for a
reason he trusts him and ended up being
one of his downfalls well yeah because
God II started telling on Sammy the bull
though so a lot of it was Sammy the bull
cuz for the first time I remember this
very well in New York gadi had they
tried to kill Sammy the Bulls I think
sister and that was very very like
he never did that there was he my
grandfather who was Sicilian my
grandmother % from Brooklyn and his
father helped a lot of guys when they
came over and then some of those guys
went on to the other stuff but my god
give me example somebody broke into our
house my grandma's house took all her
jewelry my grandfather called the guys
that he knew he just called them and
said cuz you know he would and he said
hey and he wasn't a gangster at all
he was an import/export guy and he had a
factory and he said hey they broke into
my house and took my wife's [ __ ]
jewel these scumbags I want them back
they got those jewels back they got
those jewels back in three days all of
them yeah because they knew they just
stayed that they did they went you can't
miss it
it was in the neighborhood we used to
live in Westchester I'd have to check
out exactly where but would Sam in the
booth house was right next to very close
to my it was on the same street great
Avenue
well you know they check that out I
might be wrong but I think that's what
it was Avenue 98 Grand Avenue you know
with joint with John Gotti he had a he
had a son who was 12 at the time and he
was on a bike and one of the next-door
neighbors ran him over
yeah and so the family is in mourning
right the son passed away and then
months the mom wouldn't come out of
house she's so heartbroken she would
come to the house well the guy who ran
over the sudden live behind them he was
the neighbor behind him they cease
throwing a party he's down the party
months they stone the party so mom flips
out she's like what the [ __ ] goes over
chasing the guy with a bat and while she
while the guys getting chase the guy
[ __ ] up and goes what was your 12 year
old son even doing on a bike in the
street in the first place lady and the
and the mom just goes really okay okay
walked in the house mom she talked to
her husband John Gotti you know what
happened that guy yeah he disappeared
yeah two weeks later they've never heard
from him since they inherit saw him
again never again and they had witnesses
and when they found out it was John
Gotti all witnesses might actually we
didn't see anything
during the first file with Gotti they
had guys if you were a juror they would
just have guys dead
they're at your door and you come in
they go you bring a shop and you'd be
like yeah okay we're just check-in this
women yeah
yeah and you'd see them and you'd be
like oh well this is a [ __ ] disaster
so the good thing about this country
that's different in other countries and
the reason the Mafia wasn't able to take
over was as powerful as they were you
couldn't have one ethnic group taking
over another so the Italians when they
got very powerful they were still
bucking up against the Irish police
force and the Irish weren't gonna take
that [ __ ] now of course you had a lot of
very good Italians who were you were who
were also cops this country's strength
has always been its diversity including
in fighting crime because you couldn't
have won in Mexico the problem is you
have one it's it's it's one kind of you
know it's an ethnically very similar so
it's hard but in this country we're
diverse interesting too about the
Italian mafia is it was always a way of
life for them like they made enough
money to stop but the Irish mafia the
Jewish mafia the the Mafia the money
they were making were was a means to an
end they didn't want into it where the
Italian mafia was like no we're this is
what we do this is part of our tradition
where the Irish and the Jews right nah
man we make this mine get the hell out
there's a saying where the where they
said they used to say the Jews when they
were gangsters put their money into
their kids education and into buildings
and infrastructure the Italians put
their money in mattresses it's kind of
like yeah when you're a Jewish gangster
your son was going to [ __ ] was
becoming a lawyer or a doctor it wasn't
you know we got to do this but my son's
gonna [ __ ] you know John Gotti sent
his son John Gotti junior to the
military academy because he wasn't doing
around school he's like we gotta do
something he's like I'll go to military
squeeze it right I'll send you there so
he sends him there and John Gotti junior
is like I didn't get why my dad's so
adamant about me going there and then
you come visit me he's like Jesus Christ
is cool my dad's coming
well his dad was coming
cuz he's doing business cuz the other
gangsters kids were there and then also
Donald Trump was there you know business
so he'd like it so cool my desk see me
but you be like in this big meeting all
oh Jesus Christ
really now they all sent the kids to
this military school
all the top gangsters did and Donald
Trump with their - Wow my dad sold me
this you sold it this way goes me tell
you something when you can bounce a
quarter off your bed after you've made
it there's no better feeling in the
world
that's your selling point bro that's
your [ __ ] selling point and not a girl
to be found not not one girl anywhere
high school get bouncing of the bed give
us stick to wrestling and girls my
liberal [ __ ] liberal school in
Massachusetts my boarding school I was
uh you know every day what is there a
percent about when I said he asked me
about my childhood and I was like I was
like well I mean I you know I moved
every I was moved every [ __ ] two
years to a different country and when I
was 14 I was sent to boarding school my
family was in Saudi Arabia I was sent to
boarding schools for her for years and
therapists goes like this he goes like
this he goes um they threw you away I
was I was looking at the school systems
in Texas in Austin Texas and I was just
looking at more school systems in Texas
and you know why the public school
system out there is like the best in the
nation do you know what you have any
idea be I don't know I bet you could
figure it out because they stick to real
education tried-and-true
reading writing and arithmetic and
critical thinking something that's been
lost in our higher education - no but
Barbara Bush in the bushes put all they
put
so much emphasis on public school
education cashews a teacher they power
resources into it the publicans are some
of the best in the world
good yeah we need it because the problem
is now you know what kids are gonna be
taught you watch be careful watch for
kids it's one thing to say education
education what who's teaching them what
subject you're teaching soft subjects
where there's no real science behind it
you teach them critical thinking you
teach them reading writing and
arithmetic you're really teaching in the
things that they need in life you
teaching them some are you are you a
teacher are you a political activist you
watch watch what they try to get into
the curriculums mhm and we have to push
back we have to yeah yeah what everybody
who's this you know I need anybody any
of that stuff is not good no I did in in
in colleges for the most part you know
hey let me you can't have one repeat
what's that look beyond my huge giant
dick real quick PA Pisco piss well kids
is just us cat how do you feel you're 25
I'm good I go back and forth between
forgetting that I'm not 19 and feeling
like I'm 37 on the inside that never
goes away by the way when I just shifted
my eyeballs they heard oh how are your
lids filled they're good but my covert
is not making it very happy my mother
doesn't help my mother hits me with
stuff like this
men fall off a cliff have too sweet to
be very careful I want you to go get a
meter that measures your blood level
oxygen your you know your oxygen level
in your blood or you can just go you can
go blue and I'm like alright good you
[ __ ] take it easy
dooms there my mother's calling me every
twenty minutes see if I'm dead my sister
the women of my family they like to
create lots of drama
hello no you're right you're right I'm
saying the women in my family tend to
like did they're my mother's telling me
I should be checking my blood oxygen
level and I could fall off a cliff on
the week
because a lot of men she knows for men
that fell off a cliff they were fine and
bone and so she's worried about me and
fell off and like they died or they just
got worse there's no you get worse get
worse
yeah how about how about I told my dad
you know I finally told him and he I
tell my dad I've actually had pretty
mild symptoms not a big of a deal and
then pause four five six he goes that's
fair like people people want you to have
worse symptoms like what's wrong with
people a lot of people wish we were way
sicker and I don't blame him cuz we've
been talking a big [ __ ] game like
idiots we've been [ __ ] like blah blah
blah blah blah bout co-head now both of
us I deserve it he wasn't careful here's
the thing I don't know how by the way
you know how we got it I'm telling you
how we got it you can say whatever you
want when you were coming off stage
first of all it didn't help that the
shared of you we shared a mic it's not
that I'm gonna tell you what it is
because we all came in there negative
what happened was we happen to have gone
to the one County that was the hot spot
in the United States we got an Amber
Alert on phone Saturday when Amber Alert
I mean yeah that's that's that's crazy
because man we got there Thursday
inspite well I read I think was Friday
that's cases it spiked in Arizona in
Texas so I was like oh you know we're
already there so we were in the hot spot
in San Antonio and we were on stage with
350 people whatever who are laughing in
our direction and so that's an aerosol
and then when we got offstage because
the way lol club is we had to walk
through the entire crowd people are
standing up and they're they're they're
you know I'm talking to you Ryan Brennan
and they're laughing and they're taking
so you're getting all of that spittle
yeah that's what happens they pray right
yeah I mean they did this
so aside from being in a hazmat suit
that was gonna happen maybe the larger
issue is you know should we have gone in
the first place but I again I say well
the board of and the state and the club
okay
that they okayed it in fact Levi's crew
are we weren't even restricted we I
think we had we were allowed to be more
than 75% of capacity
I know I mean so if I could redo it I
wouldn't have gone I'm me too
I've been humbled again I apologize I
understand we have to mean everybody has
to be more careful listen to us talking
now you gotta if you've been exposed you
just got to be more careful I wasn't
well she got chin all right had to
resign the other day because while he
was on a zoom meeting he was afraid that
he wasn't gonna have enough time to take
a shower and then go run his errands
shortly after so he decided to minimize
the zoom meeting which he thought would
shut off his camera but did uh and he
took a shower he brought his laptop into
the shower with him so he could still
talk and be a part of the meeting while
he took a shower and very quickly a
bunch of people realized what was
happening he had a lot of colleagues
tried to call him give him a heads-up
people in the meeting or kind of look
around like someone gonna tell him it's
someone good let him know that he didn't
exit it out and he ended up yeah there's
I think a couple photos going around so
he made a mistake because he deserved
shower no he didn't get fired he chose
to resign himself why why I'm sorry I I
don't know exactly why he chose to
resign I think he it something along the
lines of he thought it was a bad look
for the office if he stayed you know
somebody said that to him that's what he
was forced into resignation autumn the
bottom corner right here it's already
blurred out but you can see she showed
everything
[Music]
[Laughter]
well we have to resign for god sakes no
I mean you know you could be in better
shape but [ __ ] it yeah what's going on
he ended up saying that he was not
embarrassed by being nude or anyone
seeing him nude and that's okay so in
Mongolia there have been multiple cases
of the bubonic plague coming back and
it's wrong for a while yeah they're
currently at a level three warning which
basically just means that they shouldn't
be eating anything that would be
associated with rats yeah it's just one
particular ferret or whatever that is
that carries it for a long time it
sounds like more like news because in in
in Mongolia that particular rat carries
this so once in a while they've got a
[ __ ] case so it's like hey Kovac
let's add to that with bubonic plague
yeah black cat indeed do you guys have
all I do is read news right I don't look
at social media all I do is [ __ ] read
news well quarantine
have you guys seen the great white shark
attacks and the tiger deaths no some
some lady she was uh she worked at a zoo
in England and someone messed up and
left you know one of the doors up or
down and she was washing the window and
the tiger went oh well cool and it
they sit severed her spine and then
mauled her arms and legs killed her
obviously right Oh
instantly and then severed its
tightening it's at what they do
they severed her
spine well that's what they do they bite
you by the back and then that can they
crush your yeah and then in Australia in
Australia I think there's been through
already just in this summer there's been
three death by a great white shark Jesus
Christ Jesus I don't like that at all
also don't swell so I'm not swimming in
Australia it's rare don't care that's
what they keep saying it's rare oh my
god yes I hear about all the time yeah
yeah box jellyfish they have [ __ ]
great whites the too many things in
Australia that I I'll stay on the sand
I'm not getting in that water my I told
you a long time ago the girl I was
dating a girl who let me she said I have
to go back to South Africa so I said my
sister's fiance was killed right in
front of her she just saw blood they
never saw him again
a great white just went I'll take him I
don't mean to laugh but it's just water
and she said I just saw I just heard a
splash and I saw blood and I never saw
him again he just disappeared
it's a giant fish I mean God knows and
took him entirely
it's like these scientists were down
there with um with these cameras and
they were studying great whites and
whatever the kid one of the great whites
went I'm turning around I'm gonna eat
you put the guy and just went down but
that's what they do min I'm in imagine
but it's also like they this shark this
great white you bit this dude flag off
and kill them they found they salt they
they had a drone over it it was the
biggest great white you've ever seen and
because if it kills a person they
usually want to try and kill them well
that shark went oh man it seems like I
upset people well should we go super
deep and then they lost that's right
because it's the ocean oh he does it's a
mile deep yeah great white shark yep the
tiger I guess makes sense although it's
like you have this time
nothing that's not that's that that's
not fair either because the tiger you
have to keep in a cage because it's
Tiger I know and they're like well once
the tiger taste blood it's like right
well don't put in a position to taste
human blood again don't kill it well
yeah I mean obviously a terrible tragedy
for her family awful I don't know giant
great white like that
[ __ ] huge dude huge that's like San
Diego uh every time I'm down in San
Diego I remember this very well I'm
looking down there and I'm like man and
they were having a they were having a
triathlon or a big group swim and I'm
like looking at all the seals as they're
swimming that big oh [ __ ] blue water
and a deep water and I'm like you know I
just feel like there's a lot of
splashing going on well Brendan about a
month later a dentist or a doctor or
whoever had he was bitten in half by a
great white in exactly that swim fin he
was swimming and a great white was like
you know what you're slower than a seal
and I'm hungry yeah job I mean if
there's a way to go that's it I guess
laughs it doesn't make real big-time
news you guys even know about it for
God's sakes so now even that's not
making news that's fair all right you
want to see this video this is a this is
a CTA I guess it's Chicago Transit
Authority on bus driver slamming a dude
I just showed a video first holy [ __ ] he
picked him up easily he broke his back
the guy was at least walking so he seems
like he's okay but he's suing I'm sure
he's suing and wants them arrested
outside of Chicago Southside Chicago is
where 100 people were shot in one
weekend okay well just not weekend and I
think 14 people died out of 14 like six
of them were [ __ ] kids man yeah two
yeah and this is my this is my issue
with these protests it's like the real
the real the real [ __ ] tragedy is
that there are a lot of in these
neighborhoods a lot of black on black
crime it's not mean it's district it's
horrifying
tragic it's such a show so you need you
need the police for that a little
background on this story I guess the guy
that got slammed he was in the bus and
then the bus driver stopped to talk to
another bus driver and he said it was
for like ten minutes so you don't think
that he was not being professional
whatever so finally that's his side of
the story the guy that got slammed so
who was the guy he flipped like a salad
that the guy that guy was just someone
who was on the bus that complained that
they weren't being professional because
they stopped the bus for ten minutes
that's what he's saying
so then you gotta get gone and he's
chatting the night away it was also at
2:00 a.m. in the morning I'm just
thinking that maybe this guy was
probably being you know a douchebag yeah
I can smack I don't know but it's gotta
suck yeah it's gotta suck man hey let's
go here this is all so hard to watch did
you guys see this at all
the Yankees practice game and then the
pitcher but they're doing a simulated
game right they're on the same team the
pitcher gets hit by a ball from the back
I'll show you right now
I stand apparently the the pitchers fine
or he seems okay right now I said that
he had a concussion like symptoms CT
scan and it's negative his message on
Twitter was I paste [ __ ] all the support
and they feel it a bit right now but I'm
all good going to try to get back on the
mound ASAP thanks again for all the
encouraging T I be so scared of that so
I was just so scary that can always
happens like oh yeah then this guy who
rides from New York Times he writes my
baseball and said that the bat the bat
hit the ball and I guess the exit
velocity was 112 miles per hour yes
alright here's another one this is not
that new but this is a bison and this is
a wildlife park you do it drive through
it and then for whatever reason the
family in front of them they let their
kids hang out of the window I don't know
why they do this I don't get it some
white people [ __ ] get inside the [ __ ]
even the person filming it had their
windows open which is weird but uh look
it just had but those kids yeah cuz if
they're hanging out of the window for
some reason the parents let them hang
out the window so he just what the horn
actually hit the hidden kid's head
they're saying the kid is fine yeah
could have killed the kid though and
kids do get killed by these things and
they tell you they're like these are
wild animals do not get out of your car
[ __ ] huge dude yes yeah I said even a
bull even a [ __ ] regular bull don't
get don't go don't go near a bowl I was
joking around what time in Wyoming I got
out got into the pen with a bull and I
was I had and I was ready to run back
the bull just [ __ ] stopped and just
looked at me like this and I was like my
buddy goes come on come back in that
[ __ ] they can catch you yeah wait so
nothing happened though with your story
with the bull it came at me I'm glad you
asked
ervil's story I jumped in the pool
I don't strong and it came I'm gonna
kick me a moment and I relaxed my body I
did a flip landed on his ass and then
another flip it was a terrible why I got
attacked by a ball yeah I don't like
with anything man no horses cows Buffalo
especially what else you got chin let's
not look at this one it's almost funny
too I'll just play this for you
there's a backstory to this but you'll
see there you go
he's trying to have this comic get off
my girl oh this is good news remember
we're just talking about this guy The
Mighty Ducks going he's 100 yeah there
is what's lucky he looks a lot better
than before I mean I mean you got a lot
better it's a strong word but yeah that
wasn't reading you thousand one before
and then now he looks like this
who is his guardian who's this guy it's
one of his closest friends I think he's
a fellow actor he's always like washed
out for actor model train man sorry he's
caught up in that whirlwind mmm okay
this is the last one
this looked so crazy this guy's a
paraglider and he paragliding on the
couch I'll play anything for you
hopefully we play this so he designed
this thing right he's ready to go
and this looks creepy so he's not even
tied in he's not strapped in or any felt
we go high it is reaching that's nuts
this is so scary I don't know how high
up and then I'll show you he's coming in
for landing over here Brazil he's all
smiles to [ __ ] that's pretty amazing
yeah those read it's pretty [ __ ]
amazing well one little breeze would
just knock you off the couch too
yeah yeah there are a lot of things
there are a lot of things can go wrong
in that situation so turkey burger Oh
Turkey damn turkey looks beautiful yeah
it does just she's gorgeous
I'd love Turkey I've been to the islands
really twice twice incredible Turkey's
incredible turkeys like Greece the
islands are incredible and [ __ ] I
sailed around the islands in Turkey
looks cool I haven't done anything like
that and so [ __ ] long I gotta get to
Europe and I gotta get to everywhere I'm
sorry travelling in a long time you know
the house
I can't even get out of my [ __ ] house
I'm in quarantine another another
podcast in the books kids hopefully by
next week we're back in studio
Addison is being pushed everybody I
apologize for that but I think it's in
good taste and I think it makes sense
and I gotta make it better and we got to
see what the [ __ ] is really going on
with this thing and I hope I hope we
overcome this whole thing I mean I'm
talking about as a nation there's a
world this [ __ ] common thing it's
shut us down for too long we will kids
yeah this is funny kid route remember
fam this Saturday UFC 251 what a great
way to celebrate the weekend by watching
the biggest UFC of the summer and making
Bank with draft kings there's a bunch of
underdogs you got Maas it off three to
100 dog you got Jose Aldo of slight
two-to-one underdog got max Holloway
underdog now Paige Vanzant the biggest
dog on the car watch the fights make
money do it all with draft kings sign up
with draft kings and right now download
the top rated draft King sports book app
use the code fighter when you sign up
for another time all new users can get a
signup bonus up to $1,000
that's right $1,000 draftkings sports
because a sign a bonus of $1,000 just
enter the code fighter when he signed up
only a draft King sports book you'll see
251 and draft kings make
good luck Betty